So, if we take a look at this image here, this is the gizmo essentially that you'll
be presented with when you go to create a landscape.
So to enter this mode, if I go into my empty project here, and I've already entered it
here but I'll go from scratch.
So you can see if I've got a completely blank level, I can go to my landscape mode and I'll
straight away be presented with the landscape creation tool.
It's without any landscape to actually edit and have like you need to something to create.
So let's take a look at what each section of this actually means.
So I'm going to go back to my slides so that we can see it a little bit clearer.
But essentially we've got the yellow outline here which is going to be the landscape actor
edge itself.
So that's the edge of the full landscape considering everything.
Then we've got these light green lines here which might even be easier to see on the landscape
creation tool here but you've got the lighter green lines in the middle here and they're
going to be our landscape component edges.
Then we've got the sort of medium green lines here which are going to be the landscape section
edge and then we've got each individual quad of the landscape itself.
So that's the sort of color coding that gives you the information about how your landscape
is going to be set up once you press create.
Now it's important to understand how landscapes are divided.
Landscapes are divided into multiple components which are essentially Unreal's base unit of
rendering, visibility calculations and collisions.
This is pertaining to the landscape specifically by the way and this isn't something that
is relevant to anything else other than landscape.
So components themselves in a landscape are all the same size and are always going to
be square.
Now the size of these components are going to be decided when the landscape is created
and the choice is going to essentially depend on the size and detail of landscape that you
want to create.
Now components can optionally be divided into either one or four in two by two subsections.
So using the four subsections gives you the same size of a height map as using four times
as many components as a landscape with only one subsection each.
However it's important to understand that using fewer components generally gives better
performance so sometimes it's actually better to get a little bit more resolution and use
fewer components than going for less vertices overall and more components.
So that's something to keep in mind when creating your landscapes.
Now when we go to actually create a landscape one of the things that's really important
is to understand what scale we want to set our z height at because that's going to define
the height that the landscape is actually going to have.
Now if I take a look at it what we're talking about here in engine is this scale here that's
set to 100 by default.
Now what we want to be thinking of is a ratio of 1 over 512.
Now what does this actually mean?
When we import custom height maps we need to use this ratio to understand the correct
height depth that we want to use.
So essentially Unreal Engine is going to try and calculate the overall height of your height
map based on this information that you're feeding in.
So the height or the height or z value of our height map is going to be stored used
in values between minus 256 and 255.992 and this is important to understand as well that
it's stored with 16 bit position.
So when you create your textures and want to import them into Unreal for the height
information of a terrain or landscape you need to make sure that they're exported with
16 bit position.
So it's important to understand then that with that information and the standing a scale
value of 1 results in a maximum height of around 256 centimeters and maximum depth going
down of minus 256 centimeters which is really small.
By default then because we have a scale of 100 it means that our landscape range is going
to have a value between 256 meters going up and minus 256 meters going down.
If we wanted to actually calculate this in a more real world case scenario we can take
a look at Mauna Kea inside of Hawaii which is the highest peak of Hawaii at 4027 meters.
If we wanted to create this landscape within Unreal and we wanted to calculate what the
z height of this landscape should be we'd have to go by the following method.
So we take the height and turn it into centimeters because that's the Unreal Engine units we'd
be using and that centimeter we multiply by that ratio that we defined in the previous
slide.
So the overall height or z height or z scale of our landscape here would have to be 821.6
and we didn't put this in here in our actual landscape scale section here on the create
tab.
Now the only problem with this is that this doesn't actually account for the amount of
actual mountain that goes underneath in the deep under the sea below sea level.
So the way we'd actually calculate this properly would be to include that.
So if we included that which is another 5,761 meters we would add these two together which
gives you an overall number of centimeters of 996,800 centimeters then we'd multiply
that by our ratio and that's the actual height that we'd want to be using to take into account
that sort of sea level and beneath sea information about this mountain.
So that's the kind of real world case scenario which you'd want to use to calculate the correct
sizes and z height specifically for your landscape.
Now when we actually go to create a landscape Epic has already provided us with a really
handy chart that gives us recommended sizes that will essentially allow us to maximize
the area that we're using while minimizing the number of landscape components that we
have to create.
So this chart is actually a really good resource to use when trying to determine the size of
the landscape you want to use.
If you use a size that isn't on this list essentially your landscape will have to make
an extra row of components and vertices that might cause errors or undesirable results.
So if we were to actually create a landscape we'd want to use this chart and the way we'd
go about it let's say for example we want to create a smallish 253 by 253 landscape
we would essentially follow the chart itself to get the right values.
So I would go to my overall resolution here and go to 253 by 253.
You can see Unreal Engine is already going to sort of automatically try and adjust to
the things that we're actually trying to create here.
So you can see I've got a 253 by 253, 2 by 2 subsections and 63 by 63 sections per component
sorry section sizes.
So if we take a look at the chart at this here this is essentially the landscape that
I'd be making.
It's really quite straightforward once you start to use it and Unreal Engine is going
to actually take over and do as much as it can for you but it's good to always go to
this chart to make sure that you stick to these sizes in order to get a nice performance
and not so error prone landscape itself.